what's the point in success if the road
to get there is paved with nails and you
don't care about the place that you
arrive at in the end another lesson that
I learned from Adam mastriani this is an
extra special type of tragedy a tragedy
that unfolds while everyone cheers
strangling your passions and exchange
for an elite to life is like being on
the Titanic after the iceberg water up
to your chin with everybody telling you
that you're so lucky to be on the
greatest steam ship of all time and the
Titanic is indeed so huge and wonderful
that you can't help but agree but you're
also feeling a bit cold and wet at the
moment and you're not sure why
strangling your passions in exchange for
an elite life I Lov that Insight don't
forget having things isn't fun getting
things is fun but once you have them
it's not that fun the journey is the
destination and if you strangle your
passions in return for an elite life as
you start to get to the top the bar of
increasing your trajectory becomes
harder and harder if you are miserable
you're sacrificing the thing that you
want which is happiness for the thing
which you're supposed to get it which is
success